>> Bret: PALESTINIANS ARE
CONTINUING TO SHOW FURY OVER THE
MOVING OF THE U.S. EMBASSY TO
JERUSALEM, AND OF THE SUPPORT OF
THAT MOVE BY OTHER NATIONS.
THIS COMES AS ISRAEL FACES
INTERNATIONAL PRESSURE OVER ITS
USE OF DEADLY FORCE TO DEFEND
ITS BORDER WITH GAZA.
CORRESPONDENT CONOR POWELL HAS
THE LATEST FROM JERUSALEM.
>> GUATEMALA IS OUR FRIEND.
>> Reporter: IS >> Reporter:
ISRAEL CELEBRATED THE OPENING OF
ANOTHER FOREIGN EMBASSY,
GUATEMALA BECAME THE SECOND
COUNTRY TO MOVE ITS EMBASSY TO
THE HOLY CITY.
BUT THE FALLOUT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CONTROVERSIAL
DECISION CONTINUES.
HOSPITALS AND     IN GAZA REMAIN
HOSPITALS AND     IN GAZA REMAII
HOSPITALS AND     IN GAZA REMAIU
HOSPITALS AND     IN GAZA REMAIS
STATE OF CRISIS AFTER TROOPS
KILLED 60 AND INJURED MANY
OTHERS DURING VIOLENT FLASHES
DURING ISRAEL'S SECURITY FLASH
DON MIKE PENCE ON MONDAY.
FOR TWO MONTHS, THEY HAVE
INSISTED NOT BE LIFTED.
ISRAEL'S RESPONSE TO THE WEEKLY
DEMONSTRATIONS AND ITS POLICY OF
USING LIVE AMMUNITION ON BOTH
VIOLENT AND NONVIOLENT
PROTESTERS IS DRAWING
INTERNATIONAL CONDEMNATION.
>> LETHAL FORCE MAY ONLY BE USED
AS A MOUSE A MEASURE OF LAST,
NOT FIRST, RESORT.
AN ATTEMPT TO APPROACH OR
CROSSING OR DAMAGING THE
GREENLINE DOES NOT AMOUNT TO
THREAT OR LIFE.
>> AMONG THE CASUALTIES WERE
CHILDREN AND JOURNALISTS.
ISRAEL SAID THAT MANY OF THOSE
KILLED WERE HAMAS BUILT MILITANS
KILLED WERE HAMAS BUILT MILITANA
KILLED WERE HAMAS BUILT MILITAND
THEIR EFFORTS TO BREACHED THE
OFFENSE FOR A SECURITY RISK RISK
OFFENSE FOR A SECURITY RISK RIS
RISK.
I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE SECURITY COUNCIL.
HE WHO AMONG US WOULD ACCEPT
THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY ON YOUR
BORDER?
>> AFTERWARDS, HALEY THEN WALKED
OUT OF THE MEETING WHEN THE
PALESTINIAN ENVOY BEGAN SPEAKING
PALESTINIAN ENVOY BEGAN SPEAKIN
SPEAKING.
>> THERE WERE SOME SIGNS TONIGHT
THAT THERE WERE EFFORTS TO LOWER
THE TENSIONS IN GAZA, BUT WE
UNDERSTAND IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES THAT ISRAEL HAS LAUNCHED